bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat c'est le dossier sensible de ce
début d'année
la réforme territoriale après la
nouvelle carte des régions les
compétences des différents échelons avec
la fameuse loi notre pour nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république je vous propose aujourd'hui
de revenir sur cette audition par la
commission des lois des deux ministres
en charge de la réforme
marylise lebranchu et andré vallini
alors que contient ce texte quelles sont
ses orientations et bien aux grandes
régions les compétences stratégiques
développement économique innovation au
département les solidarités sociales et
territoriales avec le rsa par exemple et
aux communes et intercommunalités la
proximité le gouvernement a dû reculer
sur les départements il n'est plus
question de les supprimer en tout cas
pas pour l'instant mais cela n'a pas
suffi à calmer l'inquiétude et surtout
la colère de certains sénateurs
direction tout de suite la salle
clemenceau nous avons voulu élargir un
petit peu le spectre des personnalités
auditionnées en allant au delà des
auditions des représentants de la
fonction publique territoriale des
représentants des grandes associations
d'élus et nous avons notamment rencontré
des personnalités étrangères
des universitaires nous nous sommes
déplacés comme vous le faites vous même
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
dans tout dans toutes nos régions vous
laisse vous étiez en basse normandie
vendredi dernier nous nous sommes
déplacés pour rencontrer les élus en
situation et parler concrètement avec
avec eux nous avons essayé aussi de
faire se manifester les forces vives
organisations syndicales entreprises
pour mesurer ce qu'elle pouvait attendre
de la réforme territoriale et la
commission des lois s'est dotée de deux
rapporteurs
compte tenu de l'importance de ce projet
monsieur vendirent ndong qui avait été
désignée je crois fin juin ou début
juillet dernier qui s'est mis au travail
au coeur de l'été à procéder lui-même à
de nombreuses auditions et puis au début
du mois d'octobre monsieur le président
jean jacques qui est qui a été désigné
comme co rapporteurs le la lisibilité
politique de ce double choix est
évidemment très clair nous avons un
rapporteur qui est membre du groupe
socialiste et rapporteur qui est membre
du groupe ump ça ne représente pas tous
les groupes du sénat
mais ça montre la volonté d'essayer de
faire un travail qui s'inscrivent dans
la recherche d'un consensus
j'espère que pourront le trouver nous
avons eu l'occasion d'en discuter
ensemble
alors je vous propose madame la ministre
monsieur de ministres de vous laisser la
parole
et puis ensuite nous aurons un échange
d'abord avec l'intervention de nos
rapporteur et puis ceux des collègues
qui le souhaiteront prendront la parole
le soir pour intervenir et manifester
leurs propres convictions sur le sujet
soit pour vous interroger si vous avez
un petit peu de temps vous pourrez leur
répondre ensuite merci beaucoup vous
avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est vrai que nous avons fait monsieur
le président avec andré vallini
un tour de france avec des débats
républicains à huis clos parce que
c'était plus simple pour les uns et les
autres de s'exprimer de façon très très
libre même si on fait confiance à nos
amis de la presse c'était l'idéal et
c'est vrai que le dernier était
effectivement vendredi à caen on a pu
enrichir
le texte évoluer sur un certain nombre
de points même si tout reste on débat on
sait très bien qu'on pourrait avoir un
débat à l'infini un moment donné il
faudra trancher et avoir un texte de loi
c'est ce qui nous réunit ce matin
d'abord dire un mot de l'état d'esprit
andré vallini on est premiers témoins
comme moi le premier ministre et
président de république souhaite que sur
ce texte en avance maximum sur des
accords en amont avec le parlement le
parlement a vraiment sa place et toute
sa place et en particulier bien
évidemment le sénat dans cette
discussion
l'idée étant de ne pas avoir jeu je
parle tout à fait librement aussi après
avoir échangé quelques mots avec le
président du groupe ump qui ne peut pas
être là parce qu'il a une session
budgétaire dans son département et qui
me disait donc il faut qu'on fasse
permettez moi l'expression est de la
mettre entre guillemets mieux que pour
la carte régionale et le cheminement du
texte le premier ministre nous a donc
demandé de travailler sur les quelques
points qui font débat mais qui ne font
pas débat forcément à l'intérieur de
famille une politique de façon très
bloquée mais sont souvent trans partisan
on l'a bien vu au cours de nos échanges
et quand on dit qu'on entend dire
souvent vous avez changé d'avis sur les
départements bien évidemment oui c'est
ça se voit puisque les départements
figurent dans le texte
et quand on fait quand on croise à la
fois la question constitutionnelle la
nécessité d'avoir des majorités d'une
part et la question des solidarités
territoriales d'autre part premier
ministre a tranché avec l'accord du
président de la république en disant on
a donc un mandat devant nous pour nous
poser ensemble je dis bien ensemble
toutes les questions concernant les
départements revanche des dés la
discussion de ce texte de loi il faut
que nous soyons attentifs aux
compétiteurs compétences essentielles et
au vrai sens du mot quand doivent
toujours être confiée à cet échelon il
est vrai et je le rappelle toujours dans
les débats que nous pouvons avoir ici ou
là il est vrai que plusieurs thèses
ce sont non pas affronter mais ont été
posés sur la table dans le rapport de
monsieur raffarin premier ministre du
sénateur et ardent défenseur de la
décentralisation accompagné de monsieur
krattinger on avait effectivement une
vision qui étaient des très grandes
régions en maintenant des départements
ou bien des petites régions en
supprimant des départements et on voit
bien qu'on a fait la moitié du chemin
parce qu'on n'a pas les très grandes
régions du rapport à frencq ratages et
puisque c'était dans ma mémoire cette
huile région mais dirigeant suffisamment
grande pour qu'on se pose l'échelon de
la proximité du lien entre la région et
en particulier le bloc communal et
d'aucuns désignent à ce moment là très
évidemment le département même si est
pas remis dans les familles politiques
du sénat le débat n'est pas non plus et
pardonnez moi très trans partisan même
si sur certaines métropoles la question
reste posée sur un certain nombre des
compétences donc j'ai fini cette
introduction aurait fini cette
introduction en vous disant à quel point
nous souhaitons trouver le plus d'accord
possible sur ce texte
ce texte fait suite donc à la loi
mapanes qui a créé des métropoles en
france mais a créé un outil que je moi
j'estime essentiel qui est la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique qui
permet aux uns et aux autres d'adapter
les en particulier la gestion des
compétences à la réalité géographique
historique de des régions de france
qu'il ne se ressemblent pas et donc
l'état a reconnu le fait
qu'effectivement les régions sont
diverses et que sur ce point des
compétences qui peuvent être déléguées
en infrarégionales par exemple il faut
faire confiance aux élus ils sont
parfaitement incapable de trouver des
accords au niveau de chaque région de
france
il faut malgré tout renforcer les
régions et renforcer les régions avec
une compétence en matière d'économie du
développement économique est une
compétence majeure puisque allie à la
fois l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche le développement les
transferts de technologie à une notion
de stratégie sur quel secteur on
privilégie dans telle ou telle région
qu'est ce qu'on espère en obtenir comme
création d'emplois dans l'avenir donc
bref volet stratégique du développement
économique qui manque ou sans doute à
notre pays qui est victime de cette
fameuse antienne de la fin du xxème
siècle qui était que l'économie des
services allaient substituer des emplois
à l'économie industrielle et c'était une
erreur il faut continuer à travailler
sur les deux piliers de l'économie des
services et de l'industrie et donc un
retour un industrie implique que les
régions aient cette stratégie
naturellement en discussions avec
l'ensemble de leur territoire
pour ce faire elles sont les seules
pouvoir aider directement les
entreprises je pense que c'est une
demande de beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
d'avoir une simplification concernant
les aides directes et on élargit cette
possibilité d aide directe à la
possibilité d'entrer au capital dans des
cadres définis qui sont les quatre
créations sur un certain nombre de
secteurs
j'étais bien entrer au capital mais
temporairement un développement qui crée
problème à l'intérieur d'une entreprise
on sait tous que de très très gros
marché peuvent provoquer une difficulté
puisque les intrants
il faut naturellement les payer et on
n'a pas tout de suite son retour en
vendre nos produits donc et des cas très
particuliers dans lesquelles nous avons
malheureusement vu des entreprises en
grande difficulté ou être achetés alors
même qu'elles auraient pu être sauvées
être en pleine forme aujourd'hui si on
avait permis cette entrée plus rapide ou
capital qui aujourd'hui demandent un
passage devant le conseil d'état
donc être direct entrée temporaire au
capital tout ce qu'il y ait au ticket de
dead en terme des banques publiques des
pays mais aussi accord passé avec les
pays on a eu de longs échanges à
bruxelles avec les deux commissaires en
charge
il semble en effet que sur laitiers
bancaire de longue durée par exemple les
régions pourraient être amenés à
discuter de leurs garanties sur des
secteurs hautement risqué en termes de
technologie en particulier qu'elle
conçoit de nature donc les régions sont
confortées elles sont confortés sur tout
ce qui est enseignement professionnel
pendant formation professionnelle et la
question a été posée par un certain
nombre d'entre vous de l'enseignement
professionnel je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit bien clair pour l'instant dans la
loi ne figure que la formation
professionnelle et la discussion sur la
carte des formations parce que c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
concurrences qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
entre d'enseignement initiale ils ces
professionnels ou techniques et les
formations de type apprentissage ou
récurrents ce quelle qu'en soit la
nature porté par les chambres des
métiers et chambre de commerce ou
d'autres organisations dont on a besoin
de cette rationalisation en revanche
nous ne sommes pas allés jusqu'à ce que
un certain nombre de vos collègues ont
demandé et l'enseignement professionnel
les régions conduisait énormément de
schémas ce qui veut dire beaucoup
d'études beaucoup de recherches beaucoup
de temps car beaucoup de dépenses
publiques et nous pensons que ces études
les régions sont contraintes de les
faire de l'éconduire pardon mais elles
sont pas forcément utile donc l'idée
c'est de dire on arrête de faire autant
de schéma on en fait deux ont fait le
schéma régional du développement
économique de l'internationalisation des
entreprises et de l'exportation avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui seront
présents équipes ont effectivement
discuté des nouveaux créneaux dont je
parlais tout à l'heure à choisir par les
régions bien évidemment et puis un
schéma régional d'aménagement du
territoire non pas à la parcelle même
pas au territoire communal
mais un schéma en particulier portant
sur les mobilités les infrastructures
parce que c'est vrai qu'on voit aussi
émerger des scot et parfois des pmu qui
se construisent autour de leur histoire
et qui voit arriver un pôle gare par
exemple ou d'intermodalité qui change
tout et qui les oblige à tout
recommencer donc d'où l'idée d'avoir un
vrai engagement des régions sur un
certain nombre d'infrastructures
structurantes en terme en particulier de
mobilité mais aussi de localisation je
parle de laboratoires de recherche ou
autre outil de ce type et qui permettent
à prêts aux collectivités et au bloc
communal en particulier de mieux
travailler sur les côtés et les pmi donc
ce schéma remet ouvre discussions là on
l'a bien vu sur ce conte son contenu
sont nos possibilités ou sa cohérence
voilà je veux pas aller plus loin je
sais que poser la question dans beaucoup
de groupes sur l'exécutif et délibératif
mais nous n'avons pas voulu ouvrir ce
sujet qui nous sommes pas relevé en tout
cas on devrait aligner mois partageants
cette idée relever immédiatement des
compétences mais bien d'un autre d'une
autre
d'un autre texte de loi s'il fallait il
y arriver même et surtout débat est
naturellement enrichissant et acceptable
sur le département la nouveauté en fait
effectivement c'est la fin d'un peu plus
de compétence générale comme pour les
régions mais la création d'une
compétence solidarité territoriale qui
n'existe plus
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui en fait ce
sont des politiques des deux communes
que conduit sa majorité des départements
et comment décrire une compétence de ce
type quand il n'y a pas de clause de
compétence générale
elle avait été supprimée ce qui
interdisait toute intervention sur
l'économie quand on disait toute
intervention sur les écoles interdisait
toute intervention sur beaucoup de
d'objets donc nous dans un premier temps
avions pensé que la bonne idée était de
rouvrir en fin de réinscrire cette
clause de compétence générale et après
vos débats nos débats nos échanges la
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique nous en sommes arrivés plus tôt
à la notion de clause de solidarité
territoriale est un projet structurant
important pour une commune où pourraient
intercours un pays pour un pôle de
développement territorial ou toute autre
organisation des communes qui ne
sortirait pas sans une aide d'un
département serait dommageable au
redressement du pays donc l'idée c'est
bien que c'est la solidarité
territoriale qui conduit les politiques
du département
en prenant en compte le fait que
beaucoup de zones rurales ou montagnarde
en particulier ont un gros problème
d'ingénierie et cette clause de
solidarité territoriale peut comprendre
l'organisation d'une ingénierie
départemental à disposition des communes
je n'irais pas plus vite puisque plus
loin par dont nous avons cinq ans après
pour nous poser des questions sur les
structures départementales nous ne
sommes pas du tout près sur ce sujet
c'est mais je pense que les politiques
doivent pas pouvoir dire que on peut
avoir une idée qu'il semble rationnelle
de jean françois copé
françois hollande en passant par manuel
marquez de supprimer une structure et
puis de se rendre compte que c'est pas
si simple que ça à la fois
constitutionnellement départements sont
dans la constitution donc il faut une
majorité
et puis pratiquement donc on a cinq ans
pour trouver la solution moi je dis on a
trois quatre ans pour se poser
d'ailleurs des questions sachant que
dans cette phrase enfin face vardon
transitoire de cinq ans les compétences
sociales et de solidarité sont celles
qui sont le plus observé par nos
concitoyens qui demande à la fois l'aide
aux personnes et l'aide aux territoires
les plus en difficulté et aux communes
les plus fragiles non je m'arrête pas
pour les départements pour ce c'est
l'essentiel
ce qui fait débat aujourd'hui partout
cerrutti collège c'est vraiment le débat
tel que je le ressens et je crois andré
a vécu la même chose sur les territoires
que nous avons visités ces zones est il
opportun de transférer les routes tient
l'ensemble des mobilités pour qu'il y
ait plus de cohérence et de coordination
entre telle route tel cartel tra entre
les régions et les départements
est ce que c'est une discussion qui
relève de la commission de la commission
territoriale d'action publique moi il me
semblait que oui et l'idée des collèges
est venue d'un constat c'est que sur un
certain nombre de cités scolaires en
milieu urbain comme en milieu rural on a
aujourd'hui trois employeurs pour les
personnels non enseignants dans les
collèges les régions et les attendant
donc avec un sujet de rationalité qui a
été posée pour les cités scolaires et je
sais que ça fait débat donc je ne vais
pas au delà ce matin sur les
intercommunalités parce que je vais le
puits de possibles ce que je sais que
vous avez tous lu le texte et relu le
texte que vous avez depuis le mois de
juin sur le bloc communal
entre-temps donc le 15 décembre à 9
heures nous discuterons de la ppl de
monsieur pélissard et madame pires bonne
sur les communes nouvelles
les communes nouvelles
c'est un sujet qu'il n'existait pas et
j'ai envie de dire il ya quelques 2 ans
ou est extrêmement peu soulevé et
et de plus en plus discuté parce que
nous nous élus locaux prennent en charge
un certain nombre de politiques
publiques et pense avec juste raison que
certaines communes ne pourront pas faire
face pour des raisons de population mais
pas seulement pour des raisons d'
assiettes fiscales dire que quand on n'a
pas suffisamment d'acier de fiscale
c'est difficile de générer des
politiques publiques qui par ailleurs
sont très demandées par nos concitoyens
puisqu'il y compris en milieu rural ce
que nous disent les élus locaux c'est la
montée des demandes de politiques
nouvelles on pense à la petite enfance
et à différents accompagnements qui
quelques années
naples est un de politiques publiques
compte tenu des structures familiales
locales donc on a un vrai sujet
aujourd'hui et qui génère donc forme non
pas d'engouement monsieur le président
nous ne sommes pas tout à fait là mais
au moins d'interrogations sur les
communes nouvelles qui seront discutées
à 9 heures le 15 décembre dans
l'enceinte de cette haute assemblée
en revanche pour les uns pour les
communes les intercommunalités il nous
semble que la clause de compétence
générale est indispensable je crois que
c'est largement partagée surtout les
barreaux ensuite sur deux points forts
la disparition d'un certain nombre de
syndicats intercommunaux nous faisons
a observé que beaucoup de syndicats
intercommunaux sans correspondre à des
périmètres de pci ou infra et c'est
quand même une 17 milliards de dépenses
mais 9 milliards de fonctionnement donc
là il ya une vraie interrogation
collective à voir et donc nous voulons
supprimer le maximum de syndicats
communaux intercommunaux à vocation
unique ou multiple il me rétorque à
chaque fois et je pense que andré
vallini et thierry mandon qui faisait
une réunion sur la simplification a eu
la même question c'est certains
syndicats départementaux qui fonctionne
bien s'il ya des syndicats
départementaux qui fonctionne bien
enfin pourquoi on demanderait dès
supprimés dire c'est vraiment la
recherche la d'efficacité qui prime
si un syndicat raison d'être et à peu de
frais de fonctionnement par rapport à ce
qu'ils apportent à l'ensemble de nos
citoyens il n'y a pas de raison de le
faire mais c'est vrai que nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait un maximum de
deux syndicats qui disparaissent alors
il ya hors comptes rendus si vous le
permettez un élu goguenard qui me disait
supprimant les indemnités je pense que
c'est plus profond que ça à notre sujet
porte vraiment sur la rationalisation la
rationalité de nos engagements et la
rationalisation des dépenses publiques
je pense qu'il faut faire un gros effort
sur le syndicat intercommunaux sur
l'horizon des 20000 habitants premier
ministre a répondu dès avant l'été ou
juste à la sortie de l'été devant les
élus de la montagne
en disant qu'il n'y aurait forcément
dans la loi un article d'adaptation on
pensait qu'il suffisait plus tôt que
chacun en convenait d'une puisque
c'était un article est très déclaratif
liées plus déclaratif et normatif si je
peux me permettre
il utilise d'ailleurs la clause de
revoyure de 2015 qui figurait dans un
article dans la loi de 2010 avec un
amendement de monsieur pélissard sur un
report au 31 décembre 2012
donc on utilise le même véhicule pour
ouvrir la discussion sur les syndics sur
les périmètres des intercommunalités
mais avec donc des adaptations et nos
deux critères adaptation après avoir
rencontré beaucoup d'élus dont le
premier ministre et les élus de la
montagne c'est bien la densité
démographique qui doit être un fait
objectif d'adaptation possible et la
distance la distance en temps de
distance parce que c'est pas du tout la
même chose d'avoir une quatre voies un
train rapide ou d'être à 10 heures aller
retour d'une capitale régionale
c'est pas du tout de même nature donc
c'est bien la distance entre le centre
de cette intercommunalité et sa
frontière qui compte
moi je ne crois pas à la vision
conférence sur tous les sujets je pense
que les rencontres entre élus sont
riches et on doit pouvoir continuer à
les faire d'ailleurs elles sont légales
et
est intéressant donc l'idée c'est
d'avoir ces deux critères densité
démographique et distance tant de
distance pour éviter d'avoir des
intercoms qui chercheraient les familles
d'habitants mais qui n'aurait plus de
sens je faisais anecdote en disant que
je suis allé marcher entre ces hausses
étaient lourdes parce que je vous les
appréciez aussi compris physiquement ce
qu'est une intercommunalité de montagne
et on voit bien que les mamies
d'habitants et c'est un peu difficile de
les trouver dans des limites
raisonnables
j'ajoute autre chose monsieur le
président suite à votre discussion que
nous avons eue vendredi moi je je je
cours andré et moi on est tout à fait à
l'unisson sur cette écoute quand vous
avez une interco de 18000 390 habitants
en zones de vitalité démographique il
faut pas à tout prix la casse et la
raison l'emportera sur une une
contrainte qui n'est pas mathématique
mais qui est un objectif et cet objectif
est liée au fait que la ressource
fiscale est rare on en convient tout ce
qu'il faudra bien évidemment réformer la
dgf pour prendre en compte le fait que
nous voulons protéger les terres
agricoles les espaces naturels et qu'en
fait de quoi il faudra trouver un autre
critère que le seul bâti pour déterminer
les dotations de l'état
parce que aujourd'hui elles ne sont
déterminées que par le bâti et c'est
vrai que nous avons un vrai sujet
d'évolution de la dgf faut prendre en
compte la problématique particulière des
territoires ruraux qui doivent protéger
nos terres agricoles les espaces
naturels et j'en passe et donc nous
avons à côté de cet objectif de révision
desdits gf andré vallini et moi nous
sommes donnés le mois de juillet pour
avoir un mois de juin pardon pour avoir
une proposition bâti avec nos services
et des parlementaires qui voudront bien
travailler avec nous il faut entre temps
prendre en compte la ces
intercommunalités pour leurs périmètres
donc les préféreront une instruction
simple et on verra avec vous quelle est
la modalité puisque l'idée c'est bien
d'avoir une réunion départementale des
commissions intercommunales mais d'avoir
en présence du préfet une vraie étude de
là
de la situation pour conduire à une
bonne rationalisation je termine sur un
point parce que je sais que tous les
autres vous les connaissez par coeur sur
les métropoles d'oka est beaucoup va
leur ouvrir le dossier des deux grandes
métropoles de paris et de marseille
à ce jour l étude de l ocde sur
l'évolution de de la valeur crée donc du
produit intérieur brut de ces deux
grandes guerres géographie française
montre qu' il faut effectivement trouver
une solution pour rationaliser les
dépenses publiques dans ces grands
ensembles où l' hyper richesse côtoient
l'hyper propreté tout le monde le sait
mais on a des vrais problèmes à régler
de logement et de transport
essentiellement sur les deux grandes
questions que se sont posées sur ces
métropoles j'ajoute sur aix et marseille
provence
une grande question de portes
méditerranéenne et de rationalisation
des équipements sur l'internet du port
en particulier du père de ses parts de
marché par rapport à gènes valence et
barcelone
on a nous toujours la même position
pense que le texte tel qu'il a été voté
était un bon texte et l'ouverture qu'on
fait aux demandes nombreuses de tous les
groupes politiques et d'un certain
nombre d'élus et de trouver un statut
sui generis pour les territoires qui
permettrait aux maires de ces
territoires d'être mieux entendus sur
des documents en particulier documents
d'urbanisme mais aussi sur leurs
priorités d'investissement donc
nous sommes favorables à cette ouverture
un statut du territoire nous ne sommes
pas favorables à ce qu'ils aient
possibilité de lever l'impôt
d'aucuns proposent la cfe l'acfe
aujourd'hui sur cette l'air de paris par
exemple de 5 à 30 ce qui provoque
beaucoup de dumping entre les
territoires
quand on peut faire une ces feux très
basse on continue d'accueillir des
locaux de sièges sociaux divers
activités économiques ans quand on ne
peut pas parce qu'il n'y a pas d'
assiettes fiscales suffisantes pour
porter les autres politiques publiques
qu'on est à 30
on n'a aucune chance d'avoir un
développement sur son territoire donc
moi je pense que pour éviter le dumping
et la concurrence se dit toujours la
concurrence c'est pas une valeur c'est
un fait il vaut mieux pour ces
coopérations pour passer de la
concurrence à la coopération
je pense que il vaut mieux lisser la cfe
même sur un long temps même sur un long
temps on peut dépasser les dix ans on
peut comprendre que de lycée quand on a
une telle différence est difficile en
revanche laissé la liberté de tous je ne
vois pas comment en respectant la
constitution on l'est sa liberté de ton
et on lisse en même temps les taux je
pense que là on arrive à il n'a pas non
seulement en droit mais me semble t'il
aussi fonctionner voilà le mieux
maintenant et de d'entendre merci madame
le ministre le ministre peut-être
monsieur le président merci de moi mon
tour pour dire que je me réjouis comme
marylise lebranchu d'être ce matin
devant la commission des lois du sénat
parce que le gouvernement marie gilles
lerouge l'acti attend beaucoup du débat
parlementaire sur ce texte qui concerne
au premier chef la haute assemblée la
chambre des collectivités locales c'est
un texte qui touche au coeur des
compétences de nos collectivités comme
le premier ministre a eu l'occasion de
vous le dire déjà mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs le 28 octobre dernier
comme il l'a dit au président larcher
comme nous en avons discuté ensemble sur
le prise en commission des lois nous
voulons vraiment que ce débat sur le
plus constructif possible et que le
sénat apporte sa contribution
essentielle à cette réforme des
compétences de nos collectivités locales
pour résumer ce texte que marylise
lebranchu vient d'exposer on peut
prendre trois trois formules aux régions
le développement économique au
département la solidarité et aux
intercommunalités la proximité et les
services de la vie quotidienne sur le
développement économique
un mot pour dire que le débat commence à
s'engager et il est passionnant sur
l'idée de détendre le développement
économique et tout ce qui concerne
l'aide aux entreprises à l'heure à
l'internationalisation des entreprises à
l'innovation
tout ce qui fait l'attractivité de
territoire d'adjoindre à tout ça à titre
expérimental dans les régions qui le
souhaiteront le service public
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi
ce serait pour le coup une oeuvre
décentralisatrice qu'on inscrirait dans
la loi je sais que vous en avez parlé en
commission vous savez que le premier
ministre a évoqué cette idée le 28
octobre et nous sommes preneurs
évidemment de débat sur ce sujet qui
n'est pas facile y compris au sein des
administrations d'état concernés
deuxième au et j'en aurai terminé cette
réforme territoriale en fait elles
viennent accompagner en quelque sorte
toutes les réformes territoriales qui
ont lieu aujourd'hui en ce moment à
l'heure où nous parlons sur nos
territoires
la crise économique et sociale et donc
la crise des finances publiques qui en
découlent et donc la baisse des
dotations que nous sommes obligés
d'infliger aux collectivités locales et
qui est dur à supporter pour elle qui
oblige les élus à faire des efforts
considérables de rationalisation de leur
gestion et bien tout ça conduit à ce que
les élus eux-mêmes conduisent sur leur
territoire des réformes
la mutualisation entre communes votre
commune et intercommunalité
l'agrandissement avant même la loi
passant éventuellement le seuil de 5
milles 1 mille l'agrandissement des
intercommunalités il y en a sur tous les
territoires dans tous les départements
désintégrer commence déjà à réfléchir à
s'agrandir encore d'autres ils sont très
réfractaires je le sais mais moi je vois
l'aspect positif de ce qui peut se
passer ici ou là des départements eux
mêmes se rapprochent mutualisation j'en
ai parlé l'autre soir en débat en séance
lorsque nous évoquions la lorsque nous
examinons la loi de finances pour 2015
des départements se rapprochent
mutualisent leurs leurs services le
loiret le loir et cher l'eure et loir la
drôme et l'ardèche
d'autres veulent aller plus loin encore
la savoie et la haute savoie je recevais
les deux présidents gaymard et monteils
l'autre jour et il veut le faire une
collectivité unique à statut particulier
des bas et compliqué enfin tout ça pour
vous dire que la crise des finances
publiques et la baisse des dotations qui
est très difficile à assumer je le
répète conduit et c'est presque un effet
positif de ces difficultés conduisent
les élus à se poser beaucoup de
questions et à bouger eux mêmes
alors si la loi que nous vous proposons
de voter permet d'aller plus loin les
accompagne et soutient et leur donne des
possibilités d'évoluer ce sera encore
mieux mais je vous le répète les locaux
font preuve de beaucoup de créativité
pour faire face aux difficultés qui sont
les leurs voilà ce que je voulais
ajouter rapidement monsieur le président
mais maintenant le mieux c'est qu'on
puisse évidemment
répondre aux questions merci monsieur le
ministre et j'allais dire chers
collègues donc bien nono rapporteurs
vont intervenir successivement et donc
monsieur vente directe donc vallini en
profiter pour dire que nous avons des
relations de travail avec vous même bien
sûr mais aussi avec vos collaborateurs
et notamment la dgcl qui sont
excellentes
il faut quand même le dire en exprimant
de la reconnaissance à cet égard et puis
posé sur le tête avant un certain nombre
de questions très précises ou de
validation
donc on a bien compris que la réforme
globale de la dgf qui devait
initialement intervenir au plf 2015 et
programmer maintenant pour le plf 2016
dans premiers renseignements deuxième
renseignement on a bien compris qu'on
n'est pas sur un texte de
décentralisation mais d'organisation
entre eux des collectivités
territoriales mais la décentralisation
va nous arriver incessamment sous peu
c'est à dire il y aura t-il y aura t-il
avant la deuxième lecture au sénat
des annonces sur des décentralisations
de service faute de service aujourd'hui
exercées par l'état vers les
collectivités
parce que dans un souci d'optimisation
de la dépense publique c'est
formidablement important d'unifier le
régime des aides économiques mais tous
nos auditions tous nos collègues souvent
nous disent mais attention il ya des
double emploi avec les échelons d'état
et
les nouvelles les nouveaux services qui
apparaîtront dans les régions qu'est ce
qu'on peut savoir de précis et en tous
les cas il y aura-t-il des mesures là
dessus parce que la revue des missions
etc
on en sait très très très peu de choses
troisièmement il n'y a pas de vraie
décentralisation sans travailler aussi
sur la déconcentration vous dire mais là
c'est plus une info que le poids pris
par les dréal les directions régionales
et est excessif cas grand nombre de
préfets 10e même qu'aujourd'hui ces
services extérieurs ne rendre plus de
compte qu'à leur administration
d'origine ministère et que s'il ya
quelque chose à faire en termes de
déconcentration
il faut se polariser sur les dréal je
vous assure que on perdrait pas son
temps un essai j'avais envie de de vous
le dire
et enfin à oui j'allais oublier j'ai une
dernière question récurrente
y aura-t-il et quand un amendement
gouvernemental sur paris et marseille
voilà je mens merci cher collègue
monsieur le président jean jacques hyest
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la ministre et monsieur le ministre de
nous avoir apporté quelques lumières
supplémentaires moi je nous avons un
texte qui date de juin 2014 qui avait un
objectif clair je le dis ah si vous
désosser le le document c'est ça et
l'étude d'impact aussi le département il
faut les vapore
je pense ou le supprimer à terme alors
c'était s'étaient évaporées ces gentils
c'est la mort douce quoi en fait hein et
puis voilà et c'est écrit c'est
l'expression de monsieur edouard
balladur oui oui mais c'est pas c'est
pas pour ça que et contrairement à ce
qu'il y avait moi je l'avais dit lors du
débat sur la délimitation des régions on
me disait non non non c'est parce qu'on
a dit c'est écrit dans l'étude d'impact
ses cris bon alors on est un peu gêné
puisque on a un texte qui ne correspond
plus à la volonté du gouvernement
puisque vous nous avez bien précisé
madame la ministre
enfin on sait pas très bien m'enfin bon
enfin nous on a compris comme ça il ya
des questions constitutionnelles donc
pas suppression du département sans
révision constitutionnelle sont là
toujours dit bien que certains édiles
contraire un moment vincee prison a pris
de droit constitutionnel et puis les des
solidarités territoriales et ben oui
c'est quand même le département malgré
tout alors voie d'eau on va agir dans un
domaine très simplement
on va reprendre la philosophie de
l'article 1er à que nous avions inscrit
dans la loi sur la délimitation des
régions avec bien entendu on nous avait
dit qu'on nous écouterait on l'a vu ce
que rien rien même même sur le rien hein
et la cmp ça a été même presque
caricatural donc on est un petit peu
inquiet on nous dit on vous écoute et
puis en fait compte ne vous préférez
peut-être un peu entendu ça serait
beaucoup mieux
alors madame la ministre nous on va
résonner je vous le dis en fonction de
effectivement clarification des
compétences
ça oui il faut arrêter que tout le monde
s'occupe de tout et tout le domaine
économique vois je vous le dis peut-être
que des collègues ne seront pas nous
avons attention 2
proposé que ce soit la région que ce
soit la région qui fixe un certain
nombre de règles parce qu'il faut il
faut en sortir quand même fac a fait son
petit truc c'est pas bien ce qu'il veut
pas dire sur le plan local c'est les
intercoms et communes et interco qui
font le les zones d'activités etc
oui bon ça mais il faut quand même qu'un
schéma et puis que tout le monde s'y
tiennent un peu bon par contre et on se
pose des questions dit on va attendre la
deuxième lecture mais nous on aimerait
bien avoir le bloc total savoir où on va
on se pose quand même une question les
régions vont avoir la compétence en
développement économique
ils ont la compétence désormais totale
en matière de formation professionnelle
avec d'ailleurs quelques réflexions sur
comment faire que il ya quand même
quelques petits soucis sur le
comportement des régions de même il faut
bien le dire
1 est ce que on privilégie ce qu'il faut
vraiment bon avec parce que c'est le
l'objectif c'est quand même la formation
professionnelle c'est la glisse sont
l'emploi pas forcément dans la région
d'ailleurs il ya toute attaque
problématique
ils sont pas résolus il faudra bien
crawl est résolu nous on s'en prend
s'intéresse à la les régions on les dit
c'est mais le lycée s'est pas seulement
lycée ça s'arrête pas en terminale il ya
toutes les formations post bac
et puis on souhaite quand même leur
donner plus de rôles dans l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche
là aussi il faudrait peut-être quand
même qu'on aille un peu plus loin si on
veut que ce soit cohérent et bien
entendu si on donne la formation
professionnelle si on donne le
développement économique
on s'y met c'est quand même un peu il
manque un hymne aucun pied à la table
c'est l'emploi c'est l'emploi
alors comment mieux associer les régions
jeudi associer le ministre fut pas à
commence à mieux associer en matière
d'emploi les régions ça c'est notre
préoccupation vraiment et on attendra
certainement pas la deuxième lecture
on va essayer de faire les propositions
parce que ça me paraît quand même très
important
voilà alors en dehors de cela écouter
les l'intercommunalité côté il ya eu un
effort considérable qui a été fait dans
notre pays on l'oubli c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble des communes
participent un opci à fiscalité propre
on avait prévu une révision parce qu'il
ya des choses qui sont pas encore
parfaitement cohérente on peut essayer
de convaincre qu'il ya des choses s'ils
correspondent pas aux bassins de vie ont
il ya quelques intercommunalités qui ont
été construites non pas pour mais contre
d'autres enfin ça existe encore un peu
de moins en moins
arrêtons de fixer des seuils qui n'ont
pas de sens qui n'ont pas de sens
franchement qui peuvent avoir un sens
vingt mille habitants seine-et-marne
toutes les intercommunalités sauf une
fonte plus de 20000 habitants ont donc
le problème est réglé
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'en
seine-et-marne tout est cohérent bon
voilà et donc je alors je n'évoque pas
bien entendu madame la ministre la
métropole parisienne avec ses extensions
c'est immense communauté inventé par le
préfet de région ça toute façon on fera
des propositions mais ça c'est en tant
que franciliens plus qu'en tant que
rapporteur de l'ensemble de la loi mecs
trayant des préoccupations locales
question réflexion merci monsieur le
président madame et monsieur les
ministres évidemment la réforme
territoriale intéresse tous nos
collègues et toutes nos commissions s'en
sont saisis en désignant des rapporteur
pour avis je vais leur proposer s'il le
souhaite
d'intervenir après les rapporteurs qui
de s'exprimer au nom de la commission
des lois monsieur savary qui rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des affaires
sociales merci oui merci madame le
ministre pour vous dire les sentiments
suite aux auditions qu'on a pu avoir et
qui parfois limite le périmètre de notre
exercice
si on veut véritablement clarifié par
exemple dire que les cams rentrer
vraiment dans le dur qui est au jour
d'aujourd'hui sont financés à 80% par
l'état 20 % pour le département
une politique strictement sanitaire n'y
a pas lieu qui est 20% département
article 40 rapprochement vous l'aviez
proposer des foyers d'accueil
médicalisés double tarification
département ars par rapport aux masses
simple tarification et à la rs ou
sécurité sociale on doit les rapprocher
simplification un seul décideur c'est le
payeur article 40
vous avez fait une avancée madame si
j'ai bien compris sur le service
d'accompagnement à l'emploi qui pourrait
d'être centralisée vous pouvez le
proposer mais si nous le proposons
transferts de charges de l'état article
40 derrière l'accompagnement au travail
vous avez l'accompagnement social
la globalisation de l'accompagnement
social
avantage on repasse l'usager au centre
du dispositif et non pas selon son
statut s'est pas statué rsa vous
dépendez du département où des têtes
politiques statut à 7
c'est ce etc on replace usagers donc un
compagnon social global confié à
l'insertion pour la partie l'insertion
sociale en complémentarité de
l'insertion professionnelle région si on
veut simplifier
si on veut simplifier et penser que
l'insertion dans le cas du parcours vers
l'emploi commencent à la partie sociale
avant d'être socioprofessionnelles et
puis professionnel puis véritablement
politique de l'emploi
si on veut simplifier compiègne
assertion vous pouvez le proposer on
peut pas article 40 donc l'exercice est
très très limité comment peut-on se
sortir de ça sinon on clarifiera rien on
aura des grandes idées des heures et des
heures de débat et on arrivera pas vers
une loi qui sera plus lisible par nos
concitoyens et je tenais à vous en
alerter parce qu'on découvre ça au fur à
mesure moi je vais travailler encore
pendant une heure à ennemis essayer de
faire les amendements pour clarifier
dans le domaine social à chaque fois
c'est un transfert de charges
quant au delà vers l'autre et c'est donc
c'est complètement bloquée et dans le
domaine social j'attire votre attention
puisque l'article 23 confié aux
métropoles notamment certaines actions
sociales le service départemental
d'action sociale c'est à dire les
assistantes sociales et il ya plus de
vision globale pour le reste du
territoire
ce qui veut dire que c'est ses limites
il faut que ce soit par exemple
facultatif et non pas obligatoire on va
travailler là dessus mais on est une
limite dans ces transferts de
compétences automatiquement d'autre part
j'ai une question précise à vous
proposer ce à propos de l'article 24
vous vous dites bien plus de compétence
générale pour les départements le grand
à 1 le plus de compétences mais vous
rendez bien compte que c'est pas
concevable de si on n'a plus la clause
de compétence générale est que le rôle
de le deuxième pied des départements de
solidarité des territoires faut trouver
quelque chose à vous trouver quelque
chose effectivement en disant on peut
continuer à accompagner financièrement
les communes
ça c'est limite parce que financièrement
les départements auront juste et moyens
de continuer leur action obligatoire et
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils dégagent
encore des moyens pour mais il faut le
mettre et c'est bien parce que nous y
sommes
attaché pour le développement rural mais
vous parlez également que nous pourrions
intervenir et contribuer au financement
d'opérations d'investissement en faveur
d'entreprises de services marge
nécessaire bien sûr aux besoins des
populations
alors je voudrais avoir un peu la
définition des entreprises de services
marchands
merci merci chers collègues est ce que
vos dame l'état peut intervenir à son
tour pour la commission des affaires
économiques dans lé rapporteur pour avis
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je suis donc pour avis sur la
queue leu leu bien évidemment la
thématique du développement économique
et c'est peut-être un peu moins complexe
que sur les autres aspects puisque là
dessus on voit que les choses ont été
clairement précisée sur la nécessité de
voir la région comme étant véritablement
porteuses de cette compétence économique
est en tout cas de l'organiser et on l'a
bien vu au travers des auditions que
nous avons pu mettre en place au niveau
de l'est des affaires économiques
la question pose plus aujourd'hui sur la
mécanique qui va permettre de construire
avec l'ensemble des niveaux de
collectivités concernées
particulièrement les territoires la
gouvernance est en tout cas la
préparation la construction du schéma
régional et sa déclinaison ensuite c'est
vrai que les questions qui vont se poser
c'est est-ce qu'il faut qu'on ait un
schéma régional qui rentre dans le
détail du détail ou est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on doit avoir quelque
chose qui reprend les grands principes
qui définissent les grands enjeux
stratégiques et comment ils se
territoriale is wrong ensuite peut-être
un autre niveau c'est à dire au travers
de contrats territoriaux de conventions
territoriales et on voit bien que tout
ce qu'on entend convergent là dessus et
sur la nécessité est latent des
territoires et des collectivités des
intercommunalités quelle qu'elle soit
bien évidemment et bien d'être
complètement en phase est en tout cas
durablement branché au travers des ct ap
sur cette construction partager ça
ressort fortement
il ya une question que je me pose est
telle que le texte sur la compétence
économique et rédigé aujourd'hui alors
c'est un point de détail mais quand même
qui est important on dit que ce schéma
régional va veiller à ce que les aides
ne contribue pas aux délocalisations
d'activités économiques au sein du nhs
jean houde une région limitrophe et dans
le même temps on voit que en ce qui
concerne les métropoles on aura deux
schémas qui seront adoptées
conjointement et qu'à défaut d'accord
les orientations adoptées par la
métropole concernés doivent prendre en
compte le schéma régional
cette question des métropoles et la
façon dont on doit prendre en compte
mais on n'est pas obligé de les prendre
en compte
attention peut-être et si on pouvait
avoir des précisions sur le risque
qu'une métropole puisse et bien avoir
des règles du jeu dz effectivement
économique qui serait délivrée à des
entreprises ou des dispositions qui
serait peut-être différent du reste de
la région
en tout cas j'aimerais avoir madame la
ministre à ce stade des indications sur
comment on analyse cet aspect des choses
dans le texte
à ce stade est le dernier point je sais
qu'il est le souci de nos deux
co-rapporteurs c'est celui de
l'ingénierie économique
comment vous imaginez la construction et
le pilotage ou en tout cas la
coordination des ingénieries économiques
présentes sur un territoire régional
sans pour autant les insérer dans
quelque chose de rigide du rigide qui
pourrait peut-être donné l'envi de se
désengager à certains niveaux
mais comment aujourd'hui voyez vous
imaginez vous au niveau du gouvernement
une structuration intelligente et en
même temps soucieuse de laisser de la
souplesse aux territoires
merci chers collègues nous avons eu
plusieurs demandes d'intervention la
première est celle de monsieur captain
bac
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame lebranchu elle
concerne à la métropole de paris sujet
que je connais bien et je suis déjà
depuis plusieurs mois nous avons bien
compris que les élus de la métropole de
paris ont fait des propositions mais qui
remettent en cause le schéma tel qu'il a
été voulu par la loi métropole il ya
maintenant quelques mois et avant même
que la loi ne soit en application en
demandant à ce que les conseils de
territoire soit reconnu et une capacité
juridique mais surtout à ce que ces
conseils de territoires puissent
lever l'impôt et garde un impôt la cfe
qui est dynamique et qui risque de faire
perdurer des inégalités très forte entre
les différents territoires de la
métropole
donc moi j'adhère complètement à
l'analyse que vous faites et est la
ligne rouge que vous mettez dans
l'évolution possible de la loi m'a pas
mais je crois comme l'a demandé le
rapporteur rené vandierendonck qu'il
faut que nous puissions disposer de
l'amendement gouvernemental très vite
puisque le texte devait être examiné en
commission le dise qu'il va arriver en
séance le 16 et qu' il est difficile de
se positionner et de réagir sur un
amendement qui pour le moment n'est pas
rédigée n'a pas été communiqué
donc moi je suis en attente de
l'amendement gouvernemental pour
éventuellement faire des propositions
d'amélioration
même si j'adhère à la démarche qui est
la vôtre mais je crois qu'il reste des
questions qui sont encore à traiter
comme la démocratie dans ces conseils de
territoire puisqu'on va donner plus de
pouvoir conseiller territoire une
capacité juridique
il faut aussi à mon avis que les
oppositions puisse être représenté et
aujourd'hui le mode de scrutin est la
désignation des conseillers dans ces
conseils de territoire risque d'écarter
dans la plupart des communes
d'ile-de-france les oppositions
municipales
ça ne sera pas positif pour la
démocratie surtout ses conseillers
territoire soit un ajout un rôle se pose
également l'article la question de
l'articulation entre le consommateur et
toi et la métropole
quelles compétences comment les choses
peuvent s'organiser de manière cohérente
pour ne pas créer un échelon
supplémentaire qui risque de paralyser
encore plus le fonctionnement à
l'échelle de la métropole de paris
puisqu'on le voit à travers cette
demande des élus de la métropole où
risquons d'arriver à la création d'un
cinquième échelon puisqu'on aura sur
l'acropole de paris la commune le
conseil de territoire le département la
métropole et la région et donc tout ça
risque de complexifier et ne jouera pas
forcément en faveur d'une clarification
et donc ça sera ma troisième
interrogation la première c'est la
démocratie comment améliorer
l'articulation concerter avec toi
métropole mais quid des départements sur
le territoire de la métropole il ya
quatre départements paris et les trois
départements de la petite couronne lors
du débat vous étiez engagé à ce qu'une
étude
être présenté au parlement sur les
conditions qui pourrait être celle d'une
suppression d'une fusion des quatre
départements
j'aimerais savoir également où en est le
gouvernement sur la réflexion concernant
les départements sur un métropole de
paris nous avons bien compris que sur
l'ensemble du territoire les
départements elles et perdurer encore
quelques temps et peut-être même très
longtemps mais sur la métropole de paris
je crois que la question se pose
vraiment donc voilà les questions que je
souhaitais vous posez en insistant sur
le fait que plus vite on aura
l'amendement
plus vite on pourra réfléchir faire des
propositions et améliorer l'amendement
merci cher collègue monsieur le
président tueur merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre
j'avais une question à poser elle est
assez courte
les quel est votre dessin d eux de s e i
n wii points d'interrogation je pensais
m'arrêter là mais je voulais dire que ce
débat ait marqué du fait qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de d'éléments successifs qui
sont arrivées de position c'est que
successives et changeante
on peut théoriser cela en disant après
tout nous sommes en réflexion
la réalité est souvent comme cela
monsieur y est ce la réalité ne consiste
pas dire il ya chez ba il s'applique non
j'ai remarqué mais je vous ai regardés
et non non non mais tout à fait mais ça
me calme un très très amicale donc la
réalité cher ministre n'est pas qu'il y
a un schéma a priori picon l'appliquent
mais moi je rêve toujours d'une loi qui
dise nous voulons repenser la france
l'organisation autour de régions fortes
et de communautés fortes qu'elles soient
métropole communauté d'agglomération
communautés urbaines ou communautés de
communes
et je pense qu'il y a là une grande
clarté une grande logique
alors bien entendu je sais bien que ça
suppose des évolutions quant à la
structure départementale et qu'il était
sans doute imprudent d'annoncer que
celle-ci disparaîtrait un jour j mais en
même temps ce n'est pas je crois trop
demander que de demander vers où on va
et autant je crois que le département
reste nécessaire dans certaines
circonstances on a beaucoup parlé des
départements dits ruraux
autant je crois qu'il faut affirmer
clairement cette orientation
parce que sinon on est toujours dans un
entre deux alors on peut théoriser
l'entre-deux en disant c'est bien comme
ça c'est pas dogmatique en effet mais
c'est pas mal non plus d'afficher une
perspective et moi dans certains des
discours qui ont été tenus par
l'exécutif j'ai senti clairement cette
perspective à certaines époques
certaines semaines et j'aimerais que
l'on porte peut-être davantage cette
perspective bon mais je vais arrêter là
pour ce jour monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président madame tasca si
monsieur le président vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus sur votre état
d'esprit concernant la compétence
générale parce que le gouvernement a
beaucoup hésité sur ce sujet et j'avoue
personnellement ne plus très bien voir
comment cette réflexion s'inscrit dans
le texte tel qu'il est aujourd'hui et
comment on mène à la fois le chantier de
la clarification des compétences tout en
ménageant une part de compétence
générale
autre question concernant la
clarification des compétences mais
ma collègue valérie létard l'a déjà
évoqué comment pensez-vous articuler la
compétence économique des régions et la
compétence économique des métropoles je
pense qu'il ya là un terrain très très
important et il me semble que l'article
3 du projet de loi n'apporte pas pour le
moment de réponse claire sur sur cette
question l'intercommunalité c'est
évidemment au centre de cette réforme
en fait de la démarche qui a été engagé
par notre pays depuis la loi de 99
essentiellement et ses eaux au coeur de
la transformation du paysage
administrative de notre pays alors pour
les intercommunalités
le passage du seuil de 5000 à 20000
habitants a fait couler déjà beaucoup
d'encre et inspire quand même beaucoup
d'inquiétudes sur certains territoires
j'ai bien noté madame la ministre que
vous évoquez un article d'adaptation et
vous avez même et non ces deux critères
qui nous semblent père pertinents mais
pas toujours facile à combiner le
critère de la densité démographique est
le critère de la distance en temps au
fond pour préserver la nécessaire
proximité
mais est-ce que ce seuil de 20 milles
vous avez des éléments qui vous font
penser que c'est un seuil d'efficacité
pardon
bon voilà donc cette question enfin mais
jean pierre sueur vient de l'évoquer
qu'est devenu l'idée de faire un sort
particulier aux départements ruraux où
en est la réflexion du gouvernement sur
ce plan puis une dernière question plus
elle plus plus technique à l'article 33
il est prévu une action récursoire de
l'état vers les collectivités en cas de
condamnation pour manquement à une
disposition européenne
cette proposition est ce qu il ne me
semble pas qu'elle reflète une faiblesse
du contrôle de légalité des
collectivités j'ai terminé monsieur le
président voilà pour cette audition
parfois houleuses des deux ministres
marylise lebranchu et andré vallini en
charge de la fameuse loi notre pour loi
sur la nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république la loi sur
les compétences des différents échelons
une loi qui porte bien son nom vous avez
pu le voir car les sénateurs sont bien
décidés à se l'approprier
depuis cette audition est bien la
commission des lois a proposé sa version
du texte une version sensiblement
différente de ce que voulait le
gouvernement
une version qui arrive dès la semaine
prochaine en séance au sénat
vous pouvez voir et revoir toutes ses
auditions sur notre site publicsenat.fr
tout de suite le journal présenté par
delphine girard très bonne journée à
vous sur les chaînes parlementaires